Wait, but he's he's apologized. Yeah, but the damage is done.
>> Dude, bad day to be an Ethan fan, huh? Dude, you're
I come up with the most outlandish theories to just make Ethan
not a bad person. DON'T SAY IT OUT LOUD. SHUT THE [__]
UP. WHATEVER, MAN. You've fired Okay, it it just keeps getting
worse.
>> I read this last night and I I said, "This seems like
something someone might want to address." So, this is quick daily
reminder that Ethan from H3 likely who has his own children.
It's a comment. Funny. Everybody's laughing. >> The the
Destiny thing about Ethan and his kids, that was one of those
where I was like, "Oh, man. I think I I stepped too far out with
this one." I'm sorry to Ethan and Ethan's family for
putting that nasty Destiny comment out there. I felt like it
was an okay thing to do based on the point I was making, but
it gross shouldn't be spread like that. So, let me tell you a
little
The second iDubbbz stopped talking about
happened to coincide
when I took into my um service some fine Canadian um defamation
lawyers that sent a letter to Anisa
>> and uh Ian demanding
a retraction
and a halting of the defamatory statements that I my children.
He's apologized. Yeah, but the damage is done. So, this apology
was not because I see people they're taking this to mean that
you threatened them and that in response he's apologizing. No,
he's just doing >> Oh, okay. They're desperate to prevent
Got you. And they've preemptively apologized out of pure um patheticness.
So, I've got the Papa Gut VOD here. Papa Gut, if you remember
last night, we were reacting to Papa Gut, okay? And Papa Gut,
he was saying, essentially, that like there's no way Ethan was
suing iDubbbz, right? He didn't believe it when it was brought
up. He was like shocked that it was possibly happening. And so
now, this is him reacting to Ethan Klein and his decision to
sue iDubbbz. If you guys haven't been paying attention or following,
this has been kind of crazy today. Everybody's trying to distance.
Everybody's running away from Ethan Klein. They can see him for
what he's been, so obviously, for the past year, year and a half,
2 years? Maybe for the past 5 years. This disgusting, spineless,
wretched creature. And that's who he is. He's probably been this
for a long time. It's really, really unfortunate. But he's had
a sweeper, okay? He's had Nicholas Deorio sweeping for him. Now,
if you watched us do the Keemstar reaction yesterday with Papa
Gut here, when we reacted when he was reacting to the Keemstar
video, he swept on every single point. He was actively attempting
to sweep on every single point. It was nuts.
All right?
So, he is heavily invested in Ethan. Lawyers that specialize
in defamation
by the way,
I really don't think that's okay
thing to put out. Do you think anybody actually looked at what
iDubbbz said and was like, "Oh, this is definitely not what iDubbbz
said. This is what Destiny said. This is what iDubbbz highlighted."
and went like, "Oh, this is real." like Some fine Canadian, um,
defamation lawyers had sent a letter to Anisa. He's already losing
it. He's already losing it a little bit. Do you remember >> Remember
this guy? I am. >> a retraction and a
>> of the defamatory statements, my my And the day after
that, >> Okay. the scorched [snorts] earth goon was slaying.
Like Smaug, one There was only one scale shown, and it was the
threat of a >> Cool. All right.
Cool, man. You know, here here's my thing. Obviously, this lawsuit's
petty. It literally only exists to bully them. Fine. But like,
do you really think that we were going to get in the mud with
you and be like, "Yeah, yeah, I love you. Eat the cloud." It's
too [__] fallen. Every single time that he's gotten
in the mud, you've all jumped in right behind him. So, he probably
figured you were all going to do the same thing you guys have
done every single time before this.
Did you really think that just because we jumped in the mud with
you five more five times in the recent past that we would go
in the sixth time with you? Did you really think that? Yeah,
he thought that, obviously. One of losers who have nothing left
that would be stupid and snarking you. We get it. You know, you
put some snark energy into the atmosphere too. It's not pretend,
you know, you get you get pretty intense sometimes. We get it,
human skulls happen, that's not good. CPS happen, that's not
good. But, you know, you just like randomly decided when these
people are completely useless. Nobody believes anything that
they're saying and they're signal boosting Destiny which you
for some reason aren't suing him. Nobody Nobody thought it was
like a real threat. And you're like, "Oh, let me bully this guy.
Let me use my money to go after this guy for no [snorts] other
reason to humiliate him. And then let me announce it and be like,
"Yeah, everybody's going to think I'm so cool." So, what what
you could have done it and then not highlighted it off. Yeah?
Oh my god. Oh my god. Wait, did he just wake up? Did I just miss
him waking up? Did we just get a spark of sentience from Papa
Bowey? You get pretty intense
We get it, human skulls happen, that's not good. CPS happen,
that's not good.
you know, you just like randomly decided when these people are
completely useless. Nobody believes anything that they're saying
and they're signal boosting Destiny which you for some reason
aren't suing him. Nobody Nobody thought it was like a real threat.
And you're like, "Oh, let me bully this guy. Let me use my money
to go after this guy for no
And now, can we just be clear that there is Hey, Papa,
you dumb [__] What is the difference between that
and him going after Kacey Tron?
Kacey Tron didn't do anything. Kacey Tron did no harm.
Kacey Tron got no viewers, not really. Kacey Tron's not doing
She's not hurting anybody. Right? I understand
that you should DMCA her. That you should like make sure she
can't do that again. I could even understand saying that Hey,
I'm giving you a a notice if you ever take my [__]
again. But dude, she didn't do any actual harm to you.
She didn't do any actual harm at all. So, but guess what? Somehow
Casey Tron's like even more reviled than these people. Everyone
was totally down for people to sue Casey
And I might have even like maybe I could have possibly understood
or defended somebody stomaching that one. If his actual damages
he got were commensurate with the damages that he faced that
he suffered or if they had anything to do with getting justice
for copyright at all. They didn't.
The damages he sought, what he really wanted was to humiliate
somebody. That showed you who he was as a person. And everybody
who is paying any amount of
when he humiliated Casey Tron like that for things totally outside
of copyright, apologize for all of this.
Say you like [__] up. Say Hassan wouldn't give you
money. Talk about Hassan.
Right? When he did that, he showed who he was. He is a petty,
spiteful, tiny, spineless, litigious
And you you were riding with this guy. You totally you totally
backed that. You're totally psyched about that. And now you're
like, oh, this guy like might be a mean, psychotic, like a totally
spineless, litigious loser. Ethan, why are you acting the way
they said you were? The way every the way all these people said
you were after you sued Casey and made her do that hostage apology?
Why are you acting like that still? Dude, he just shows you every
step of the way who he is and these people will not pay attention.
Well, I guess Papa Goos is paying attention now, thankfully.
all other reason to humiliate him. And then let me announce it
and I'm like, yeah, everybody's going to think I'm so cool. So,
what what you could have done it and then not highlighted it
offline.
>> You know what I mean? Like that could have been like
a step you could have But I don't know, man. Who cares? Cool,
Like great stuff, you know what I
>> You know what I mean? It's like, wow, great. That's
why I'm just not reveling in this announcement. It's like, cool,
dude. I I know. Like iDubbbz has has fallen. They're just kicking
him down like a dog. Like I don't okay, you know, [gasps] like
it's like Don't forget Casey takes care of her sick mother while
Ethan has a cut throat. I thought it was her dad that was sick.
But regardless, I do know she takes care of like a a parent who's
got like a disability.
The only real asset she's got or one of the only real assets
she's got is her home. I think she's got a bar or something,
too. But it's like her home. And that's what was on the That
was By the way, that was why she was settling. She was never
ever going to go to that case, even if she had a case. She's
never going to go Sorry, even if she had a case, she was never
going to go and risk going to trial and getting statutory damages
that makes her lose her house. It just wasn't worth it, right?
Like she would have You could have asked her to say anything,
she would have said it.
It just It makes me It makes me feel sick. It makes my stomach
turn to watch some like
moral black hole like Ethan Klein
get leverage over somebody and then just watch him apply it publicly
in a way that he's just like clearly
getting off to.
Like he's just clearly filled with glee watching this person
under like with a gun to their head saying all the things he
wants to say. He had hold the gun to this person's head and make
her dance like a puppet. Very sick. Very ill. Okay, okay, cool,
man.
Right. It's not because they're principled. Uh yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Not principled. >> because he's above it. Okay. In
fact, they're hurting bad. Okay.
Look at him. His His fallen off so hard. So true, dude. >> It's
crazy how hard it's fallen off.
It was literally the day he stopped talking about it, right?
And then like how would you How would you even win the defamation
lawsuit if they're so fallen
Wouldn't that be an auto loss? Like you have to know that, which
means that the lawsuit like announcement is just a way to be
like It's not an auto loss. No. Even if it costs him a bunch
of money, they'll have to hire lawyers. What do you mean it's
an auto loss? He just gets to stress their finances.
That's the goal, to torture them. Because he is a like honestly
like bordering on evil
fantastic [__] okay?
He like that's just it. That's it. That's what this stream was.
Was him just like basically waving a huge flag at everybody.
Look, I'm like I'm like actually going towards evil. I have no
morals left. I am a total I am a total reprobate. I'm a total
piece of [__] Like haha I would you know I like you
can't you can't go toe-to-toe with me. So you have to do what
I want you to do. This makes this is going to make people look
at all the other lawsuits but like look back at them and go like
mm.
You know, whatever good charity you had earned, this is going
to make it look bad. Ironically, the most good charity you got
was from my disliking of horrible hippies against you and it
was so bad it backfired.
So, you know. He doesn't talk about the snark anymore. He doesn't
talk about me anymore.
And [clears throat] um they're by the way desperately
unfor- This this is the ult- He can't talk about you? it, right?
He doesn't talk about the snark anymore.
fallen off so hard.
It's crazy how hard it's fallen off.
It was literally the day he stopped talking about it, right?
He doesn't talk about the snark anymore. He doesn't talk about
me anymore. Are you saying he doesn't talk about that anymore
because of the lawsuit or he just doesn't talk about it as much
anymore cuz it's not Is that what you And um they're by the way
desperately
unfor- This this is the ultimate irony and I love this. Okay.
America, love America. Oh, cool. Me,
>> If he lived in California, I wouldn't
bother threatening to sue. Now, I think this when Ethan's talking
about this for California, I think Ethan is saying he knows that
he's getting slapped down. He's getting an anti-slap.
Like and the anti-slap [__] is going to be like perfect.
It's going to work perfectly against him. Like I think he knows
he's got no shot against Noah Samson. That's what that tells
me when he's like, "I wouldn't even bother if he was in California."
Huh?
I I'm pretty sure he's done in the No Nonsense thing. I think
him complaining about anti-SLAPP in California, oof.
Dude, I think he knows. Because of because in our great state
we have anti-SLAPP laws that make it extraordinarily
difficult
to sue
>> um public figures for defamation and we have this extra
I know this isn't exactly an option for the Keemstar video per
se, but I think the vid is going to be an all-timer because it's
making the sweepers have to make moves they would have never
made. Well, the funny thing is the funny thing is is I don't
think it's going to work. I I understand
the move they need to make is like a mea
That's the move. That's the only move. You need to talk about
what you did and why and be honest about it.
That's the only move. Anything other than a mea culpa, anything
other than admitting wrongdoing, admitting how you [__]
over other people in the process, like everything that was wrong,
right?
That's what you need to do. It's the only way out. It's going
to dog you for a long time.
Although this is actually pretty good that he's criticizing,
but like I I like that he's criticizing, but it's you have to
do a deeper analysis. The fact that he hasn't shut Castlevania
off might be proof and like all the proof I need to say Papa
is not rehabilitated, okay? This is rough. stream appreciation
for
for free speech in the First Amendment. Now, let me tell you
something. This doesn't make you look good. This makes you look
even more petty.
Wait, Top Bronson? That's a fantastic
How does anti-SLAPP make it harder?
It doesn't.
It actually doesn't at all. The only thing anti-SLAPP does is
make it harder
to use your wealth to penalize people when you don't have a case.
Isn't that so telling, actually?
That anti-SLAPP laws don't make it harder to prosecute defamation.
All they make it harder to do is to file vexatious litigation,
vexatious legal claims, to harm other
It really sucks, but I would never have done this in California,
cuz I couldn't use my wealth my wealth to bully these people
in California. It never would have worked. Oh my god.
Everything he says just just betrays a deeper rot within his
soul, doesn't it?
>> Ian, he hates America.
He wants to [clears throat] get as far away as possible. He thinks
this place sucks. So, he moved to the to the northern wall and
pledged to the Night's Watch. Okay. But Edmonton's not that bad,
man. Come on, dog. Edmonton's not that bad. They got a nice downtown
area. What the [__] Bro, even it's like an optic
nightmare, because like first of all, if you really appreciate
freedom of speech, then you wouldn't be suing. No, he is a The
answer is not that he's an optic nightmare, not that he's a deeply
good person who's just flawed, and maybe he looks a little bit
bad. No, he's a deeply sh person. He is a bad person. He is a
bad human being. No, it is not just bad optics. He is a piece
of [__] This isn't itself a sweep. "It's really bad
optics, man. I don't think this looks very good." is translated
is "Dude, Ethan, I want to like support you no matter what, so
I get free Teddy Fresh merch, but like this looks really bad,
man. Like you're doing [__] that I would look bad
if I took your side, and that makes me sad. Please don't think
Please just do things that are bad, but that I could sweep for.
If you keep it in that range, that'd be better. Please? Please?
I mean, like but second of all, you know people are just going
to be like, "Oh, he's doing like I love America thing." They're
going to associate you with the right. They're going to say like,
"Well, he's not refusing to talk about like real threats like
Asmongold." and [__] But he'll talk about I don't
know. So, so they're going to say they're going to start saying
that you're going to have more information to say that you're
Yeah, oh, trust me. I'm very much keeping track of the fact that
when Ethan had the opportunity to go after somebody who's actually
harmful and actually harmful human human being in the copyright
cases, he could have gone after Asmongold. His reaction is far
less transformative than Denims and he's a total piece of sh
But he went after Denims over petty personal grievance. In this
case, for defamation, he could go after Destiny, the person who
actually made the statement, a total piece of sh a a reprobate,
human filth. But instead, he's going to go after iDubbz over
petty
I don't know, fights, squabbles.
It's such Man, he's such a bad human being, Ethan Klein. He's
a sh person. You consider that Hasan is bad. I do not consider
that. Wow. You're It's almost like we should let let Hasan stop
dictating what we do and don't do. Like just in in general, right?
It's almost like if I'm If I have a problem with you or something
you've done and you start talking about Hasan, you should shut
the [__] up. going farther and farther right in your
right-wing chud posting.
Like now you're just like giving ammunition to Hasan's audience
to call you like a right-wing weird chud. You even made like
a weird anti-feminist comment before. Again, if I'm being charitable,
the the anti-feminist comment was [laughter] I'm assuming you
think that they're virtue signaling
But you're not exactly helping yourself there, bud.
Like what is going on here? Dude, how can you say How can Papa
Gut Listen, I'm It's hard for me to pay attention to this guy.
I'll be real.
was it not 5 minutes ago where he was basically saying like,
"Man, it seems like you're just being mean. Like you're kicking
this guy like he's a homeless guy. You're just kicking him in
the face." Like he's describing all of the things He's basically
describing Joffrey from Game of Thrones. He's describing somebody
who's like bordering on evil, who's right at the border of evil.
And then he's like, "Man, this is a real optics nightmare, man.
How do you do that? How do you You're giving ammo. You're get
You're going to let these people make you look bad, Ethan. It's
actually the same as CPS as the Oh, it's the same as everything
from before, right? No, Ethan just looks bad when you don't pay
attention. But actually, like it totally makes sense when you
know about CPS and the skulls and the Nazi sword. Ethan looks
really bad here. And I wish he He's not bad. He's not bad. He's
not bad. He just looks bad. He's not bad. He just looks bad.
Uh but let me tell you something about uh Canada.
>> The north.
The anti-slap laws wouldn't apply. Destiny admitted that the
that the statement was made with malice. So, I mean that he'd
have a valid suit against
Or would that only be in
No, iDubbz didn't make the statement. He said somebody should
address this. And then he said, "I don't agree with the statement."
So, iDubbz didn't make the statement and then say, "Well, I only
made the statement cuz I hate Ethan Klein." iDubbz didn't make
the statement. He showed the statement, said somebody should
address this, and then later it said, "I don't agree with that
statement at all. I just think someone should address it cuz
it's gross." I don't think there's any way to interpret that
as defamation, to be honest with you. Would that only be in reference
to like if you went after Destiny? Certainly, that's not a way
to You I don't see how you could possibly sue somebody for defamation
over that after they take it down and apologize after a cease
and desist. In that case, I think there's no way. Oh, are you
saying that like the reason he's not going after Destiny? Oh,
wait a minute. Wait, can you Can you confirm Mr. Ryan Beard,
can you confirm Destiny said that? Cuz if Destiny did explicitly
say that um he said it with actual malice. Destiny said it. And
then he I believe he said this person called me a So, I'm calling
them
I think so. I see. Is that what you're trying to say? Or am I
just like
everything? I wish I had the chat. >> Defamation laws ain't
quite the same up
And when [laughter and snorts] I spoke to an attor- Does that
make sense? I don't know if that makes sense. I don't know like
I don't really know the law. Like maybe that's a theory. They're
like, "Yeah, no, this
This is quite bad.
This [snorts] is definitely actionable here in Canada. In America
in California
you could say that.
Could have said that.
But in Canada Why do you think we do our show here? Exactly.
>> Exactly. Do you think I could do the show in Edmonton?
I'd be ruined.
Is this malicious?
Because everything has to tie back to me and Hasan has had a
lot of success in trying to tie people back to me. Like I said,
I think what this is why I call Ethan all the time just kids
or whatever is because Ethan gave in cuz he's a spineless hack
to this type of attack where he's like, "No, I'm not like Destiny.
Destiny doesn't get me talking boy." I think I've I think I seriously
think me and Ethan have traded two messages. I think I've gotten
one message from Ethan in my entire I'd say my lifetime.
In addition to the the admission that he knew he wasn't a in
DMs or in sorry, DG chat, I'd say so, >> that Twitter convo
convo. It was like two messages back and forth about the I never
remember. This is right after the
uh war thing. But he's like, "Hasan is convinced." Or maybe he's
not actually convinced. Maybe he just knows that this is a good
tactic. That if you try to rope people in with me enough, eventually
you can get them to like start seeing the same hallucinations
that Hasan sees. Um yeah, so that's yeah. Because What was the
There was some drama that came up with Hasan. I wish I could
remember what this was. I don't I think I feel like his community
or he might have tried to Like even here, this is 2 months ago.
More stable. Still like schizophrenic, but it's like slightly
more stable at least. >> for, but I was like driving when
it broke. I didn't cover any of it initially. And he was trying
to I think he was trying to pin it on me. I'm trying to remember
what the drama was though. It was like a a couple months ago.
Okay. Anyway, whatever. That I mean that to me, he's saying he
didn't call him cuz he thought he was a called him
he abandoned me. Ethan abandoned me. That's why I called him
a just kids is what Destiny just said.
I found me a Canadian lawyer who's pretty gung ho about suing
you. I guess cuz he would like money. He's a lawyer now.
And I might just do that.
>> And you know, he's grow Well, if he's doing this, wouldn't
that be mean that you couldn't do that if if he
I believe but he's he's apologized. Yeah, but the damage is done.
His apology was not because [snorts] I see people
Dude, you got to They're taking this to mean that you threatened
them. No. And he in response he's apologizing. No, he's just
doing >> Oh, okay. Oh my god.
>> Dude, bad day to be Ethan fan, huh? Dude, you're
Whatever, man. You've I find okay. It it just keeps getting worse.
It just keeps getting worse. Any any theory that could be concocted
that makes Ethan look o Dude, dude, you're not supposed to think
about the world this way. I come up with the most outlandish
theories to make Ethan not a BAD PERSON. DON'T SAY IT OUT LOUD.
SHUT THE [__] UP. IT'S GOOD AS POSSIBLE. It dies
instantly. Like he just said something else that just makes his
worse. Dude, Ethan Klein is operating in extra-dimensional space
cutting off every escape. Here's a way Here's a way that I possibly
with with strength there I can possibly make Ethan Klein seem
not like a monster. Oh, he cut that off.
How do I DO IT? HOW DO I DO IT?
Yeah, I Dubs apologized and I'm still I'm still doing it. Okay,
cool.
>> All right, great, man. Uh Okay, very litigious. Okay.
>> seems like you're definitely a way It seems like a definite
a definite productive usage of your time. They're desperate to
prevent litigation.
Got you. And they've preemptively apologized out of pure
um patheticness.
But you know, in my opinion because we there's no
All right. You just want to go, "I'm so sorry. Please, my principles."
>> Don't just be sorry. >> Think for Exactly. Exactly.
Thank you, Christopher. Okay. >> [__] legend.
Christian. >> Christian. Not Christopher. We're on CLOSER
TERMS. >> OH, GOOD for you. So, uh So, >> everything
I need. I might Yeah, so the defamation's already happened. We
sent them a letter saying like, "Hey, you got to stop cuz you're
the damages are just mounting up." And they stopped desperately
stopped, right? And they got a lawyer. They They desperately
stopped. >> And now we're just I don't want [clears throat]
to give away the details of our settlement because I'm I am I'm
way above that. >> Oh god, it gets It gets so much worse.
I forgot that like after he drops the lawsuit, it gets so much
worse when he gets asked questions. And then Dan Dan is clearly
annoyed with him, right? Dan is like obviously upset with him
Dude. Yeah. Yeah, Dan is actually upset with Ethan here. So,
when Ethan's like, "Oh, I'm I'm I'm like I would never give away
the details of the settlement." Dan's like, "So, you mean you're
not allowed to." He's just like making it very clear that you're
not being noble. You're You're a piece of [__] right
now. Right, Dan? I'm Here, hold on. I'm way above that. Right,
Dan? Dude, that's still the weirdest moment to me. I'm just going
to watch that again.
Now we're They stopped desperately stopped, right? >> here.
And they got a lawyer.
And now we're just I don't want [clears throat] to give away
the details of our settlement because I'm I am
I'm way above that. Right, Dan? Oh, papa got pauses. PAPA GOT
PAUSES with how awful THAT IS. PAPA GOT CAN'T MAKE IT. I'M WAY
above that.
Right, Dan? You're above giving details of the settlement? >> I res-
You've You've You've lost Dan. You've completely lost Dan. >> Dan's
not even ON YOUR SIDE.
DUDE, you can't sweep this. It's unsweepable. IT'S UNSWEEPABLE.
There is no broom strong enough. WHERE IS AUGIE? Where is Augie?
Augie's the only one who can do it. I don't think Augie wants
to. I If If anybody could, it might be Augie, but I don't know
if anybody
even wants to try, man. It's so over. If I was If I was Ethan,
I would on ironically I would operate my life based on like Dan.
Dan would be my He's my He's my Geppetto. Or no, he's the He's
the cricket.
Is that what it is? Which one is the cricket? Jiminy Cricket.
Jiminy Cricket.
>> All right. August got that make me look good. August
make me look really good, please. It seems like Dan is just like
not on your vibe, bud. He does not seem to be thrilled. Is this
just like crashing [clears throat] and burning any credible Why
is it that every time I watch the show Dan seems to be not on
the vibe? Well, he has left. respect the Canadian legal system
with the utmost care and
And you're not supposed to share any details is what >> never
I would never The Crown would never You usually share everything,
so that doesn't sound right at all. >> the Crown. Okay.
[snorts] So, it sounds like because you're not allowed to. Not
allowed to is one thing, but I just respect the Crown. >> Okay.
Got it. I will say that though. So awkward. It's so awkward,
man. >> to do it, right? Because the damages, right? To
my reputation. There's no damages to his reputation. Holy dude,
this is so stupid.
>> This is so dumb. Jesus Christ. Our um are terrible.
I feel terribly damaged. Um and there's actually [clears throat]
such a crazy funny thing about the Canadian thing too, cuz he
moved to Canada. I learned [laughter] you can't even crowd fund
Woah woah
>> for lawsuits. What? And you can't you
So, I I'm not sure the exact law, but if he did crowd fund, they'd
have to basically ID
and verify the identity of every single person that gives money.
Is he I I ironically didn't think I had no idea about that. Is
that true? No idea.
Like every [clears throat] single time he talks I'm like wow,
like everything really just leads to be like you really just
want to like humiliate this I I think it's a massively disproportionate
thing. I mean, this is ridiculous. Is anybody on this guy's side
here?
>> Let's be real and fix everything. Yeah, that's what
I'm saying. Absolutely. [__] I dubs. He's slowly
getting there, right? He's He's stopped He's like hardening the
language as it goes along, and it's because
Dan's the only person with something like It's not quite a spine,
but there's only Dan's the only one with something there a little
bit, and it That's what makes Ethan look bad. When everybody
stops clapping along, and somebody just goes, "Bro, what the
[__] happening? What Like what are you doing?" Then
the people watching can see a little bit a little bit that like,
"Oh, this actually is bad." And you can tell as soon as that
Dan moment came,
Papa Goey, he started to flip a little bit, right? It's still
not Oh, this guy's like a total piece of [__] He's
totally reprehensible. He's a He's like It should It should be
that based on what he's describing for behaviors.
Yeah, it's a little It's still too soft, but he's got to like
>> I unironically didn't think that it could get worse.
Like I didn't think it could get more dumb and petty.
>> Dumb and petty is not enough. Like every single time
he talks, I'm like, "Wow." Like everything really just leads
to be like, "You really just want to like humiliate this person."
I I think it's a massively disproportionate thing. I mean, this
is [__] ridiculous. When you consistently look to
hurt
in a massively disproportionate fashion, when you consistently
look to hurt, humiliate, denigrate your opposition. What do we
call that, class? Is anybody on this guy's side here?
>> Let's be real and fix everything. Yeah, that's what
I'm saying. Absolutely. I dubs definitely fixed his reputation
with that hippies. I even said that This just makes him look
this This is stupid, dude. This is so [__] dumb.
This is so stupid, bro.
>> Oh my god, bro.
>> Jesus Christ. You know what? I guess it's just [__]
black and white. >> I know what you mean, but >> you
got me feeling bad for [__] I >> out. Chill.
So, cool stuff, man.
Like he can't even crowdfund for it to try to like do something.
Bro, this is This really is This really is giving oppressive
millionaire vibes, [laughter] dude.
Vibes? NO, IT ISN'T A IT isn't a It is an oppressive billionaire.
You
That's literally what it is.
That's that you are a he is an oppressive millionaire. He is
a millionaire silencing free speech of people who are critical
of him or like
Was it even critical? DUDE, YOU GET YOU SUING A DRAGON DOING
A FUNNY VOICE. Oh my god, what is this?
Like you're suing a dude doing a burnt peanut but with a dragon
doing a goofy ass voice putting a screenshot of what somebody
else said on the screen. Dude, give your give your head a shake.
That's what it's giving right now. That's what it's giving right
now. Uh I don't know.
You know, this is this is a it's giving giving some interesting
vibes, dude. Okay. So, it's like >> Yeah, why is Destiny
off scot-free, dude? What the [__] going on with
that? Basically virtually impossible it would be to, you know,
do something like that on GoFundMe. Okay. So, he they're not
even capable of crowdfunding for this. The fact that he they
moved to the >> they have to do that? iDubbbz is a really
successful YouTuber. You're right. >> got a lot of money,
right? Dan, Dan, I know that you're just trying to support your
Ethan Klein right here, but I can tell with the your voice that
you were
>> I thought I thought Papa Gut was going to give him a
talking to for sweeping there. I thought Papa Gut was going to
was going to step in and go, "Dan,
I know you want to support Ethan, but it's too much now." Like
to the [laughter] maximum degree.
So, [clears throat] stop pretending. It's occurring putting his
hand on Hitler's shoulder going, "Dan, Hitler is a one Jew too
far now. It's one Jew too far." pretending. Stop pretending,
dude. Cuz we know it. Stop enabling your friend. Thanks for $2
from [__] Sharky Production. Ethan is so lame for
this. Why not go for Destiny? I think it's just to go after
>> you're right. I I assume a lot of people would want
to support them. That's all. In fact, I didn't I hear that uh
that they never have to work another day in their life? >> Anisa
said that yeah, recently. Let's give it up for the >> they're
pretty well So [cough] true. Right. So true, dude. So, [snorts]
Okay. I think I'm going to speed up
Yeah, no problem. This is about Look, this is about protecting
my family and my reputation, you know? And while I understand
one of the reasons why he's doing this now, he wants to get like
a bunch of public statements up there about how his whole family
is emotionally distressed and all this stuff. So, that's what
he brings into the lawsuit. So, he's saying publicly how his
whole family and my reputation and my reputation is harmed, blah
blah He's just doing this uh he's doing this for the lawsuit.
He's making this episode that in my opinion is harming his credibility,
especially to people who are more on his side, uh just so that
he can have more information in the lawsuit to go after iDubbbz.
That's what this is. That's That's exactly It's The wild thing
to me is how people are trying to make this significantly different
from other
It's not.
It's just not.
It's literally not even what I To be
I think it would still be made and as much as I do think it would
be funny and I would laugh about it and I I would still say it
makes Ethan Klein look worse if he sued Destiny. Like, I don't
necessarily I think basically suing somebody for like for talking
some
Right? In a way that's obviously not
I think that's made. Now, I personally think Destiny deserves
all possible like legal harm done to him, but it would still
be a vexatious lawsuit, yeah.
And I Like I
I would probably go Yeah, I would think less of Ethan if he did
it. I probably would have a hard time, really, you know, selling
the farm to to champion Destiny's cause, but I would still say,
"Yeah, it's bad. I don't want him to do that. He shouldn't do
that."
Right? And Ethan's been engaging in this kind of vexatious litigation
for a while now. And I do The only real difference here is that
it's for somebody else's words on the screen. But realistically,
Noah Samson, I think, is actually
I think there's an argument that Noah Samson defamed Ethan less
than iDubbbz
I'm not even joking when I say that. I think Noah Samson's speech
is totally
ironclad protected, and he's still being sued. I think Idubbbz
actually was worse in terms of defamation.
And nobody Nobody stands up for Noah Samson cuz they hate him.
I mean, I guess they don't like Idubbbz either, but >> what
this is cuz he's like, "Oh, my
Cuz he has to play it up like it was like a real damaging thing
to his reputation, or else people would be or else like the courts
would be like, "Oh, this is obviously not true. You obviously
don't care as much as you're letting on to or pretending to care."
The fact that he moved to Canada was was a 5D chess play um uh
against himself. Right. I mean, listen, if Idubbbz is the Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
I know The only way Idubbbz is for you to move to Canada
or kill yourself. Okay? This is the only
This is the only way, Idubbbz. You have to understand.
There are greater goals. There are greater goals at play, Idubbbz.
You have to go to Canada
and it will result in your destruction, but know
that your destruction
will also lead to the destruction of Ethan Klein.
Know that moving to Canada, you will be our martyr, Idubbbz.
You will be our martyr. You will have to go down,
but know that you will drag Ethan Klein
to hell with you. And you
will be redeemed in the end. You will get your 40 virgins
in heaven
at the highest level of paradise.
Thank you so much, Idubbbz, for your sacri- YOU YOUR MARTYRDOM
will not be forgotten.
Thank you, Idubbbz, for moving to Canada and sacrificing yourself
for all of us. Thank you. Thank you.
>> His His name was Ian Show me your hole. My god, yes.
Very good. So, I'm very happy he moved to Canada. I'm glad to
know that we have the best and brightest protecting us in the
north.
Winter's coming. Damn. I'm a woke dragon. And I wish you guys
the I'm a woke dragon. Okay. the best. Mhm. I really do. Okay.
I really really do. I So, why you know,
I didn't follow all this. What what what [laughter] Dan's so
clearly upset.
The quote was a Destiny quote. Right. But the thing is, Destiny
made it clear he didn't believe it.
Did he make that clear? I thought he made it clear that he did
believe it. No, he made it clear that he said it. He He made
it clear that he didn't believe it later, but he made it clear
that he was saying it to [__] with Ethan. Jesus Christ,
dude.
Internet versus. The Oreo stream is definitely content. Okay.
Is there a [__] Maybe I mean maybe I'm wrong. Is
there like a Dude, the Internet versus is like a who's who
of brave patriots, okay? The Internet versus of this this episode,
it's like brave patriots only, all right? >> I guess I
don't know. He did it with
What that mean Destiny did with malice? And he insisted he didn't
believe it I'm so I mean I understand that might have been sarcastic,
but that doesn't really matter. Ian didn't make the statement.
Ian looked at a statement and he said, "I don't know what this
is, but someone should address it." And then a little bit later
he goes, "And I don't even believe that. I think it's like really
gross to imply that. And I think Ethan should address it cuz
it's really gross to imply that." He's never implying he believes
that at any point. Destiny does imply he believes that at certain
points. >> He's being clearly sarcastic here when he talks
about his motivations for it. Like, "Oh, it hurt my reputation."
What? He was just doing it to be an But that's So he's saying
Somebody's saying, "Oh, when Ethan says it hurt my reputation,
he's being sarcastic?"
I don't think so. That would be really bad for a lawsuit, no?
>> he do it? Did this make
Yeah, I don't think [clears throat] Ian ever has actually believed
it. He was just doing it to be an
What's the difference? What? Can he really not understand the
difference between laughing at somebody else talking [__]
to Ethan Klein, defaming Ethan Klein, and going, "I don't think
that's cool. Uh D shouldn't do that." And Ethan going And Destiny
going, "Ethan Klein's a pedophile. He hurts kids." And then going,
"Yeah, I said that cuz he called me a too." You're You're implying
you Well, one, he says he later does admit that he didn't think
that, but he also clarifies that he said it to cause harm to
Ethan because he knew Ethan. He was mad at